last time i covered paw patrol i
convinced you that this kid ryder child
genius inventor was recruiting homeless
dogs to use as members of his crew of
rescue animals the paw patrol why well
because the missions are dangerous dogs
are cheaper and more expendable than
humans and stray dogs are the most
expendable of all now obviously what
ryder's doing there is real bad but the
crimes of ryder don't just stop there my
friends not only is he putting his dogs
into the direct line of danger with
little regard to their well-being he's
the one creating those dangerous
situations in the first place get ready
all you good pups because today we're
exposing ryder for the money hungry
criminal mastermind that he really is
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where they're all dead pups
and they'll be
replaced
cause it's just another day around
adventure bay
dead patrol so it's been a couple months
since i last covered paw patrol and due
to the blessings of owning a
four-year-old who's discovering media
for the first time i'm still watching a
ton of the show now if you've somehow
missed this gargantuan hit of a
nickelodeon series the paw patrol are a
team of six puppies led by a boy named
ryder each pup has a specialized set of
skills vehicles and tech that ryder
designs based on typical emergency
services we have chase the police dog
marshall the firefighter sky the
aviation pup rubble the construction dog
zuma for water rescue and rocky for
garbage collection episodes of the show
are a pretty classic action adventure
fair there's a problem that needs
solving somewhere in adventure bay the
paw patrol suit up and say ready for
action riders sir and then they use
their technology teamwork and winches
lots and lots of winches to make sure
that everyone winds up safe and happy
have the farm pigs run away call the paw
patrol is a plane about to crash land
call the paw patrol has the villainous
mayor of a nearby town discovered an
ancient relic in the jungle that turns
him into a monkey call the paw patrol
now the monkey magic power will be mine
yeah as you might be able to tell now
that i'm into the late seasons the
rescues get real weird don't even get me
started on the mer pups and the quest to
save poplantis pups with fishtails
so that's the premise of the show cute
simple cut and dry but if you look even
just a little bit past the surface level
you realize that not everything's peachy
keen in adventure bay in our last theory
we concluded that there were pups in the
paw patrol before the main six of the
series pups who died in the line of duty
before being callously replaced ryder
himself was the mastermind of the whole
operation finding stray and abandoned
dogs to recruit for his dangerous rescue
missions knowing full well that if they
die well they can just be easily
replaced and on top of all of that rider
doesn't even pay the pups with anything
but treats he keeps the considerable
amount of money generated from their
merch sales government contracts and
literal stolen gold coins all to himself
wow
real old-time outlaw loot so okay the
kid's a bit unethical in the way that he
treats his pups not great but overall
writer and the paw patrol are doing far
more good than bad right they're solving
problems they're saving lives it's just
what has to be done in the line of duty
it might make writer a bit of a jerk but
it doesn't make him evil right well
loyal theorists as i've continued to
watch more and more of the show my
suspicions around ryder have only
increased you see in later seasons a lot
of the problems plaguing adventure bear
caused by the various villains of the
show mayor humdinger sweetie the kitten
catastrophe crew but the technology that
they use sure looks an awful lot like
the stuff that ryder builds for the paw
patrol and that's because ryder is doing
much worse than just taking advantage of
disasters and putting innocent pups in
danger to make a quick buck as the
series goes on it seems like ryder is
the one creating the dangerous scenarios
that are putting everyone at risk he's
selling many of the villains his
technology he's hoping that they're
gonna create more trouble for the paw
patrol to solve in short rider is a war
profiteer he's an arms dealer who's
playing all the sides and in the process
he's putting both his dogs and his town
at risk oh well he literally sits atop
his ivory tower the lookout now
obviously those are big claims so let's
step back and look at the proof that
ryder has actually given his tech to the
villains shall we in season one we meet
mayor humdinger the very competitive
elected leader from the nearby town of
foggy bottom we're told that he always
wins the competitions that he enters
looks like another year on top for the
town of foggy bottom once a cake contest
winner always a cake contest winner well
that is until the paw patrol rolls into
town and suddenly helps mayor goodway
win all the contests from hot air
ballooning and cake making to cleaning
up and basketball thank you judge of
course i couldn't have done it without
your help ryder after that humdinger is
just no longer the top dog and no matter
how hard he tries he just can't seem to
win good way is always getting help from
the paw patrol which means that he's
always playing ketchup so far so good
just a little healthy competition right
well in season two sick of always losing
humdinger pulls out a new strategy a new
set of minions
presenting
the kitten catastrophe crew very good at
being very bad the kitten catastrophe
crew who are now tasked with getting a
humdinger whatever he wants they
sabotage water towers they make messes
they steal giant gold chicken statues
but here's the weird thing about the
catastrophe crew each kitten directly
maps onto a paw patrol member their pup
packs i guess cat packs have the exact
same equipment as their paw patrol
counterparts cat chase uses a zipline
and launcher just like real chase skye
has wings just like the original sky cat
rocky has a claw arm just like the dog
rocky you get the idea now at this point
you might be wondering well isn't
humdinger just super tech savvy couldn't
he have just replicated ryder's
technology rather than it being given to
him and that's what i thought at first
too except for one thing humdinger ain't
exactly what you'd call a tech whiz in
season 5 episode 17 pups save the movie
monster humdinger tries to steal a robot
monster but just doesn't understand its
controls all this remote looks
complicated maybe if i push this button
and in the paw patrol movie his complete
ignorance of technology is what causes
the cloud catcher to malfunction and
destroy adventure city now those are
just two instances but across the series
there are plenty of examples where he's
just not that great with tech that said
mayor humdinger does try to create
several inventions throughout his
appearances in the series and they're
just awful in comparison to the stuff
that we see ryder make for example in
season 3 episode 3 pups save the soccer
game humdinger creates a remote
controlled ball in an attempt to cheat
and win a soccer game and yet his remote
short circuits and breaks causing the
ball to lose control it gets so bad that
the paw patrol has to step in and save
the day now i don't know about you but a
remote controlled soccer ball seems just
a little bit less complicated than a
voice controlled cat pack with a freely
rotating fully operational robot arm and
yet it malfunctions with barely any
prompting and this isn't just a one time
thing either in season 4 episode 2 pups
save the cat show humdinger creates a
robot cat to win yet another competition
but when it trips and falls onto the
floor it goes haywire requiring the paw
patrol's intervention later in season
four this time episode 16 see patrol
pups save a shark he creates a robotic
shark that's powered by a wooden
contraption that resembles a hamster
wheel not exactly top of the line tech
but more importantly the stability of
that shark is atrocious its internal
welding gives way and the shark begins
to flood after it gets hit this is
absolutely not on par with the quality
of engineering that we see with both the
paw patrol packs and the catastrophe
crew packs which get thrown around a lot
during the rescue missions and dastardly
plots it only makes sense if ryder was
the one who created all of the tech now
it'd be one thing if the kitten
catastrophe crew were the only bad guys
to have identical pup pack tech at that
point maybe you could just write it off
as a coincidence but the catastrophe
crew are far from the only rogues in the
paw patrol gallery to use tech eerily
similar to ryder's inventions the rescue
night series introduces us to claw an
ex-knight and the villain terrorizing
the kingdom of barkingberg by the time
the paw patrol face off with this guy he
already has his own personal pup pack
with a claw that can grab things
functionally and aesthetically identical
to the packs used by the paw patrol then
in the mission paw series we meet
sweetie the pet of the princess of
barkingberg unlike what her name would
suggest sweetie is anything but she's
the biggest cause of trouble in the
mission paw series with crimes ranging
from theft to kidnapping now all of this
is possible only because of her vehicle
and her pup pack complete with a pincer
vacuum and even a selfie stick guys you
gotta keep your followers up to date on
that hashtag villainlife and once again
all of it is strikingly similar to the
designs that ryder has for the paw
patrol in fact when sweetie suits up her
attire matches the aesthetics of the
mission paw outfits that the paw patrol
is wearing mostly black with colored
accents this actually has to be one of
the biggest pieces of evidence towards
sweetie's gear being a writer original
creation see this isn't a case of
sweetie seeing the paw patrols look and
liking it enough to copy it or ryder
seeing sweetie and digging her outfit to
make it into a paw patrol uniform no
sweetie puts this outfit on before any
of the paw patrol pups puts theirs on
and the paw patrol suit up before ryder
sees sweetie in the gear this cannot be
a coincidence they have to have been
made by the same person but okay maybe
this sort of technology is just super
common in the paw patrol universe maybe
pup packs are something that you could
just order from your local best buy but
again that's not the case as we called
out in our last theory the paw patrol
are relative unknowns in this world
they're only becoming more well-known as
the series progresses because of their
daring rescues rescue dogs and
technology for cats is not something
that exists normally in this universe it
is specifically being built by one guy
ryder all right matt patti here saying
sure the tech used by sweetie claw and
the kitten catastrophe crew are similar
to the paw patrols but maybe that's just
how technology looks in this universe
that would be a fantastic explanation
for what we're seeing here a lot of
times the art direction of a show
especially an animated show can end up
with characters and technology designs
that look samey and while the paw patrol
series definitely has an art style that
it sticks to it also goes out of its way
to show that different technologies made
by different people look different
compared to the paw patrol's pup packs
we already pointed out how different and
almost primitive humdinger's tech looks
compared to riders but there are other
examples throughout the series for
example the ruff ruff pack are a group
of villainous biker dogs featured in the
moto pup series and its three members
all have pup packs as well but their
packs are way different from the ones
that we know that ryder makes every pack
that we've seen up to this point looks
very similar they're made with clean
cylindrical or cuboidal pieces and their
joints are easy to move plus they're all
colored and feature iconography that
matches the pup or kitten that they were
made for the rough rough packs gear
however looks like it was made with
limited time and resources these packs
are older rusty they're made using scrap
metal the joints are barely held
together with screws and bolts this
suggests that they were made by gaskin
who we know is an amateur inventor okay
here it is the first official ruff-ruff
pack drone so clearly the show's art
style cares enough to indicate when
technology is made by other inventors
the ruff-ruff pack scrapyard inventions
humdinger's early primitive tech but the
catastrophe crew sweetie there's no
other way to explain it it had to have
come from ryder so ryder is clearly
designing the tech that villains like
humdinger and sweetie wind up using
throughout the series but why it doesn't
necessarily seem like a great business
model to just be giving your tech away
but just look at what happens once these
villains get hold of it in season one
the pup's rescues can honestly seem
pretty trivial they help the farmers out
during the fall festival they gather up
some lost bunnies they help mayor
goodway win a few competitions and in
rare cases they fight the occasional
fire it's not exactly the high stakes
rescues that ryder was hoping for when
he started the paw patrol to make cash
off of disasters but then look at the
escalation by season seven they're being
hired out by royalty to protect the
crown jewels as private bodyguards
they're being asked by mayor goodway to
save stolen ferris wheels crimes that
are only made possible thanks to his
technology getting in the hands of the
show's villains
now what is this adorable yet strangely
suspicious kitten up to
ryder is clearly a smart kid and a
shrewd businessman and he takes his
opportunities where he sees them to come
dinger for instance clearly the
competition between the towns was
important to him and as time goes on he
gets more and more discouraged as he
loses because of the paw patrol to the
point where he's suddenly willing to
cheat in a way that he never did before
think about it in season one we never
see humdinger do anything shady we're
illegal he's just a really competitive
guy from a nearby city and yet in season
two we immediately see humdinger playing
dirty as well as ignoring both laws and
the safety of others as he destroys and
vandalizes property what's changed one
thing he now has his own minions in the
kitten catastrophe crew minions
outfitted with ryder's tech ryder saw
the competitiveness in humdinger and
exploited it he created a villain and
humdinger in the catastrophe crew to
escalate the problems that the paw
patrol could respond to suddenly they're
not just tracking down misidentified
cows in the snow they're stopping
bonafide bad guys ryder can suddenly
charge more for it he can get more
publicity for it he's now building an
empire for both his exploited rescue
pups and the technology that allows this
stuff to happen but it doesn't stop
there friends ryder expands his little
racket beyond adventure bay and even
adventure city he seeks out new
locations like barkingburg where he can
give other misguided pups some of his
tech he creates new villains and
therefore new disasters on a scale that
even he couldn't have dreamed of before
instead of a vehicle claw uses his pup
pack to find a magical dragon tooth that
lets him control a real actual dragon
which he then directs onto the people
and city of barkingburg when the paw
patrol avert that disaster ryder
couldn't ask for better publicity brave
pups led by genius boy save city from
dragon with achievements like that under
his belt just like that ryder suddenly
made himself a valuable new client for
life and the princess of barkingberg but
worst of all the kid doesn't even bother
to make sure that the bad guys see
proper justice he isn't taking the steps
required to prevent these from happening
in the future sure sweetie is often put
in the proverbial doghouse when she's
caught but she's out again by the very
next episode and a humdinger in the
kitten catastrophe crew rider doesn't
even bother to arrest them when they're
caught red-handed instead they're just
slapped with a catchphrase oh that
troublesome mayor before getting off
scot-free ready to wreak more havoc in
the very next episode ryder is the
city's law enforcement here arresting
criminals would fall under his
jurisdiction but he doesn't because that
would be bad for business one thing's
clear ryder is no hero not only does he
put the lives of his pups into constant
danger with little regard for whether
they live or die in the disasters they
face but he's responsible for creating
those disasters in the first place in
his greed ryder encourages these
misguided souls to cheat and commit
crimes in order to drive up business for
himself strengthening his empires it
spreads from city to city rider offers
them advanced tech to escalate their
crimes to new heights and then doesn't
apprehend them to prevent future crimes
rider is the paw patrol's worst enemy
the true villain of this franchise
sitting pretty atop his scrooge
mcduckian pile of cash while he puts the
lives of both his pups and innocent
people on the line sure they all may be
good pups but ryder he's bad to the bone
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
[Music]
you